you say you don't drink
um like that i've been drinking like
like we've been in the house like i've
been having like some family come over
we'll play drunk ping pong [ __ ] oh you
tell my beer pong
yeah but with shots oh that's dangerous
so you're playing beer pong with shots
oh that's
that's rough that's rough with beer bro
we started all wrong we like
had 25 cuts on each side oh yeah yeah
we learned that was a rough night we
learned
what about do you participate do you
smoke weed do you do any sort of drugs
or anything like that
hey that's dope man did you ever have a
scent in your life where you
were you were you were like you know i
strung up doing lean or anything like
that yeah lean i had
lean and lower tails i was on a bed
what is that smaller
watson's so like it's like a is it like
a percocet
oh yeah see it's okay yeah it's open
yeah
so i was going bad so that [ __ ] how long
have you been off of that because i know
that's just hard to kick
it's like you got to go through it no no
it's not it depends on how hard how hard
you go
playing if you just a weak ass person
mentally
right so you kicked it pretty easily i
like it i would never
like i need like i used to just overdo
it you feel he was like really
recreationally [ __ ] with it yeah but
i was getting like i was
eight pills a day and like fought like
one time i i [ __ ] heat splashes and
feigning inside the barbecue one time
and getting full of lean
i caught all my charges up for the drink
so
he was on lean every time he got
arrested yeah because i used to just be
like just like a zombie no just be angry
that should make you angry and it gives
you a [ __ ]
belly right i heard that [ __ ] makes you
gain weight
i think a lot of it too is like you is
all the soda you drink with it people be
[ __ ]
drinking so much goddamn soda when
they're on i was small without like 160
i wasn't gaining no weight
so you was just leaned out catching
charges
was that what kind of made you like
realize like man i'm tripping like i'm
dying
i just went to jail and i i couldn't get
it so i just stopped that's fine but
i always been a type where like i'll go
like a couple days and like
detox myself hey that's smart man a lot
of people ain't they can't say the same
thing